i want a a church of made out of bones
in my bag luckily for me there's just
one ready for purchase
does that does the price get dropped for
that that's a lot of deaths on that one
i i feel like i feel like at it's just
like an aesthetic choice you know yeah
so you kill one person in the house
suddenly no no
you kill 50 people oh no it's an
attraction
all right i see how it is
so what i'm hearing is that you should
you shouldn't stop at one you should go
the full
fully commit
it's profitable to be a serial killer
here's the idea right
you're done right you want to be you
want to make money and you want to be
comfortable first of all step one become
a serial killer you have to profit
because you go to prison right right
never to pay for a thing ever again no
taxes nothing right and then now netflix
bringing you up we'll make a true crime
doc
six figures per episode
he's just living like biscuit oliver
yeah
yeah you would be the king of the
prisoners i don't have to pay rent what
do you want from the
the prison store oh you want four packs
of ramen i'll get it
clean myself you'd just be in prison
maybe you're into that that's a slight
downside to that right slight downside
it's just like a bunker isn't it
but you'll be rich
in ramadan
do you ever want to take on a diy
project
oh yeah
i'd love to it's one of those things
that i definitely definitely definitely
when i work less in future
yeah and i get my own place is that i'm
going to have a lot like half retired
yeah yeah a lot funnier just like like
you you get the mate over here yeah it's
like like do you think this is a good
idea and he's like let's just give it a
go
what's the one thing you want to build
or like shed for sure
you want to build a shed i want to build
a shed yeah i i thought about building a
shed at my current place yeah just
because i have a lot of space but like
yeah built yeah [ __ ] i don't know what
what is it about building a shed that
it's like yeah i feel like it's like
it's like the tutorial level into like
building [ __ ] or like all like a table
i think that's the tutorial level that
that's that's
like a work table yeah building a work
table where you can do other diy
building building a [ __ ] is just like
the easy version of building a bunker
you know it's it's it's like it's it's
not a tree house you don't have to worry
about gravity it's not underground it's
just in your garden right it's sitting
there it's just sitting there yeah i
mean like right now it's annoying
because like i'll have a problem i'm
like man if i could if i just had a saw
and some wood i could like make this
thing in my apartment and just work
easier yeah yeah yeah yeah would you
ever want a man cave i guess that's the
shed yeah for sure yeah what is it about
i i don't i don't know but like
there's just something primal about
about just having your own like man cave
right i don't know why but every every
guy i know no ladies allowed
it's just a shed with like a a time
crisis machine in it it's like boys come
over here it's like pool table dartboard
i don't want to be that guy who assumes
things about genders and stuff like that
but like dude do girls want a girl cave
like i i'm genuinely curious because
everyone
room oh yeah true we're like i want i
want to be able to play osu on 4k dolby
atmos in this shed
and have a beer machine yeah that's what
i want i don't care about how it looks
it's my thing yeah more than what i
think i generally you know i'm not
assuming
normal i think
women like taking care of the whole
space
yeah exactly i don't know i don't know
if i'm correct i might just said
something also also i did also again
like in my in my opinion like just
because i'm this men just in general
just don't have a sense of interior
design like a lot of ladies do
but then you meet some guys you do me
some guys me some guys who are just like
whizzes and you're like
generally generally speaking i think the
general consensus is that a lot of guys
are just like put up poster here and
then put up something that doesn't
completely match over here whereas you
know a lot of ladies like no balance
that was probably one of the things i
hated most about moving was having to
figure out where everything goes right
yeah i didn't like that yeah because
every time you try to do it yourself
you're just like no i just did my office
and then i was like yeah i don't know
what to do for the rest yeah i just did
my office as well
i just did my office and even my office
was like [ __ ] difficult as [ __ ] to
figure out
i i had like i thought i had like the
perfect setup and then i put everything
in place and then it just looks [ __ ]
it looks [ __ ] it looks [ __ ] and i had to
like do real life sims well yeah i was
like placing things in different spaces
but unfortunately i didn't have i
couldn't just click on a button i had to
like physically move this [ __ ] heavy
ass
heavy ass desk around my room until i
found a place that i felt felt
comfortable with and i wish i could just
like see in my mind's eye where would
look the best but like my my imagination
just sucks when it comes to i wish i
wish i had that like overview camera you
know of the room where i could just see
the entire thing i'm like yes i know
exactly what this is going to look like
also like i just hate making decisions i
don't like i don't know i don't know if
that's the thing but like that the thing
decision this is why you would fail in
the zombie apocalypse
weapon i just want someone to make all
my decisions for me you know like
change my diapers
i just want to exist comfortably uh if
uh like i i want someone to make the
decisions for me i think there's like i
can just exist there's a good place
there's a good place for that i think
it's jail
honestly
you're a bashing prisoner it kind of
i think you would do the best in prison
out of the three of us
could you be in the [ __ ]
you'd be sitting in the [ __ ] corner
having a great time watching like night
kitchen nightmares in your head for the
third time yeah
me and joey would be like going crazy
absolutely that's probably true actually
yeah gant would be totally chill in
prison yeah you be friends with everyone
because no one can hate you yeah you
have no decision fatigue either because
everything's being selected for you
right
about interior design literally the most
stress-free lifestyle consider consider
it's the knowledge that if i wanted to i
could leave
if i wanted to i could make a decision
and uh and i have have my own right
right yeah
maybe you're like a make-believe
prisoner
so garn wants prison
but when but it can leave when he wants
yeah
so like like like a rehab
like a hospital
assignment
[Applause]
i'd be the easiest like uh grandparent
to take care of you know i would just
like just just just leave all folks yeah
an old folks just leave me there yeah
future child uh please do not take this
please take care of me this is just this
is just young me talking [ __ ] with the
boys please don't leave me enough please
do not leave me i just imagine you go to
your you visit your grandparents in this
old person's home and then just like
next to your seven-year-old granddad is
30
year old khan
playing so much air like
that's like i love it here it's amazing
they take care of me
have you ever thought about it because
so like no
have you ever thought about it no never
thought okay so you you have kids right
i'm sure every parent goes through this
through this phase you have kids um you
want them to take care of you when
you're older because i don't know like
many people who want to be in a
retirement home right you want to be
close to kids as possible right how do
you trick them into doing that
how did you convince your kids to do
that well this is where this is where
the past 40 years will matter guys
your kid's right yeah right right did
you raise a piece of
i [ __ ] it's all about how you raise them
how are you raised how are you were you
raised i wasn't i was i was left to fend
for myself
because because like the wolves were my
parents because for me
for you guys for you guys you got family
right you've got brothers and sisters
you can you can you can spread the load
right for me i'm like an only child so
like my parents my parents like all or
nothing for me they're like they're like
praying like praying that i don't just
wake up one day and i'm just like mom
dad i guess i guess you're going in the
retirement home today god
they're probably sweating watching this
right now
[ __ ] he's considering
depends you know because what if they
it's it's like different right if you're
like 40 50. yeah you probably have a lot
more
uh time and resources to be able to help
if you're 20 25 30 yeah you you're
barely being able to take care of
yourself also think about like you know
if you live near your parents right like
you could be you know you could be on
the other side of the planet and it's
like if they can't take care of
themselves then who's going to yeah
we're unfortunately we are three guys
who are living like very very far away
from our parents exactly
like yeah i think like we're like the
exceptions that's why my sister lives
near my parents so all the way goes to
her that's what i'm saying
do your parents need help already
having siblings is a cheat code having
it that's that's all i'm saying man like
i'm like sister good luck see you later
we all have like 15 kids